[Music]
it's been a rough year already hazard it
I'm still reeling over what happened to
re zero honestly who knows when railgun
will stabilize as well let's hope
everyone back in Japan and the ones in
the industry stay safe and strong for
now at least not all shows have been
affected yet luckily the winter season
has enough hits to keep you busy
from memes that caused a ripple effect
all over the industry two great shows
that you'd hate to miss the season is
actually far stronger than it first
seemed to be while we anxiously wait for
the fate of the supposedly stacked
spring season how about taking some time
to finish up some loose ends this winter
with these shows Nando
[Music]
at the forefront of our list of best
shows this winter 2020 is Darwin's game
2020 future dairy anyone the story of
pseudos mundane life being dragged into
a death game and a battle for survival
is not looking to be everyone's top
choice for anime of the season but it
sure is one entertaining right in
addition to Konami zazz Shiro Amir
powers anime fans can find a lot of
familiar elements in Darwin's game that
would ease them into finding a comfort
zone while watching the show develop the
action is fun and I think that the
character dynamics are ultimately the
show strongest point I just think it's a
shame that the show's likely to only run
for one core because of the short run
we're not likely to see an adaptation of
the latter arcs that detail more of the
reasons for the death game and further
develop the characters nevertheless with
what we have I think Darwin's games
exciting enough to stand on its own and
the arc that took up half of the
sheduled episodes has been a treat to
watch with its twists and great action
sure they cut the Occident they don't
cut off up next at number nine is smile
down the runway you know with me always
saying that it's a guy has done the
masterful job of tweaking itself and
reinventing some tropes in order to give
it its long shelf life that we see today
there is something that I neglected to
tell you if Sakai isn't the king of
taking pretty much any setting and topic
and applying his trademark Flair in
order to make it appealing sports anime
is as we'll see later now why am I
telling you this smile down the runway
is not a sports anime in any sense well
it follows to Yuki a young aspiring girl
who dreams to be a star model however
things don't go as planned for her and
she finds herself physically unable to
become a professional model you see you
have to be a certain height in order to
make it and such is the cruelty of this
world nonetheless help is on the way as
Chi Yuki meets a classmate who has
talent in designing clothes together
can the two make the impossible possible
now doesn't that sound like the formula
for a good old underdog story entering
the world of cutthroat competition it's
not a sports anime but it sure seems
like one from the sound of things even
if you're not that interested in the
topic of fashion design I'm sure that
smiled down the runway we'll keep your
buds glued as you watch too Yuki's
journey towards success that's just how
good the shounen anime formula is and
from experience it manages to take
something seemingly so unrelated like
fashion design and weave it into such a
compelling story this show completely
flew under the radar for me before the
season and now I don't regret watching
it one bit for our eighth entry we take
a journey to a fantasy world with Somali
and the forest spirit taking place in a
world of spirits and monsters humans
have long been driven to near extinction
however this isn't your gritty
humanity's resistance show that you
would have come to expect from settings
instead is the story of Somali one of
the few remaining humans and the golem
who serves as the forest guardian spirit
the chance encounter triggers a parental
bond between the two and they begin
their journey of exploring the world
together it's magical it's pretty and
it's as wholesome as you can get for a
modern anime Somali and the forest
spirit is a story of the twos genie and
the growth of the bond between father
and daughter the show reminds me of some
good ol Ghibli films
thanks to those high fantasy worlds that
are just ripe for exploration and
discovery in contrast to the RPG
settings or the war-torn Imperial
kingdoms that we often see in fantasy so
Molly takes us to what reminds me of the
magical world of fairy tales and
childhood storybooks somebody and the
forest spirit is a unique experience for
this day and age and is surely a
wholesome one that you and the family
can enjoy together special mention to
the masterfully sung ending song by REMS
voice actress which had me hooked for
hours on end
and just as we finish with a wholesome
show it's time to get the popcorn ready
for some controversy probably the most
influential anime on the list in the
real world is coming next on the list at
7 interspecies reviewers you have to be
living under a rock to not feel the
waves that this show sent across the
community months ago I know
Funimation and my anime list would be
remembering this show for a long long
time now what is this show about and why
did it caused so much controversy well
to put it simply it's about three
buddies going around and sleeping with
different species of creatures and
publishing reviews about how each
experience feels to them it might be one
of the boldest ideas to make it to ecchi
anime in the recent years and it really
showed given how much attention the West
has given it honestly speaking the anime
probably wouldn't be in any way helpful
in terms of teaching you the meaning of
life giving you a new perspective or
anything like that nonetheless if you're
the type who wants to get his seasonal
dose of edgy content here's a show you
might be pleasantly surprised about
interspecies reviewers might not be for
everyone but it certainly offers a
unique take as a member of the ecchi Jon
Roth which has somewhat been stagnating
over the past few years I mean I
personally prefer my classic fanservice
shows like no game no life or prison
school but you could check this one out
to see what all the fuss is about
for our sixth anime on the list it's
time to dive back into the world of MMOs
with the hit anime Bo Furi I wonder how
you guys assigned stats in MMORPGs do
you go all the way and throw all stat
points in one relevant stat would you
try to balance every stat out possibly
turning yourself into a jack of all
trades master of none type if you're the
former type of player you might be able
to relate to maples dilemma allocating
all of her stat points to defense due to
her fear of pain Qaida finds herself in
a pickle in NWO new world online lacking
magic speed or anything else which is
relevant
her character maple ends up being unable
to do anything of relevance whatsoever
however it does turn out that jacking up
her defense that much does come with
some nifty benefits such as the skill
absolute defense and the ability to kill
things with counters armed with a unique
setup she partners with a friend Risa
playing as the swash buckling Sally and
they go on plenty of adventures in NWO
thus begins a cute and light-hearted
adventure across an MMO world with the
best adventure duo you could ask for it
may not be the most in-depth or
realistic MMO show out there but that's
exactly where Bo Furi derives its charms
from it's cute entertaining and
extremely relaxed in a way it kind of
reminds me of the SAO alternative the
spin-off anime starring Len
in that it's a cheer show about gamers
playing video games at least before the
real-life circumstances started getting
dragged into GGO
[Music]
at number five is toilet bound hinako
Kuhn it seems to be a big thing with
schools in Japanese media but the
concept of the seven mysteries or seven
wonders seems to be quite common schools
are after all prime locations for
hauntings and stories of encounters with
creatures that go bump in the night
karma my Academy is no exception as it's
the place where the legend of hinako son
a ghost of a girl haunting toilets lives
on rumors state that hinako would grant
her summoner any wish this is enough to
try and push many students to try and
summon her including Nene Yoshiro whose
desperate for someone to return her
feelings turns out that hinako is
actually a boy and threw some twists and
turns
Nene finds herself as hinako's assistant
who ends up being entangled in the world
of the supernatural
little did she know that hinako is not
merely a toilet bound ghost but also a
guardian maintaining the balance between
the human and spirit worlds
coming into the season I had high
expectations for Dora hey Dora and was
expecting it to be a smash hit given the
source materials popularity and its cult
following
while that explosive popularity hasn't
materialized I think that the show is
doing quite well for itself really
anyway entering the fray of manga
adaptations with the basic premise of a
man out on the hunt for magicians who
turned his head into a lizards Dora hid
Dora's carved itself into a nice niche
in the anime community while its CGI has
been a source of debate its plot
development characters and overall
atmosphere have been praised by most
people who have watched it also it's
worth noting that Dora hey Dora is not
an edge vest that you'd expect from a
violent and gory setting like this
instead
it carries itself with a unique tone
that allows it to be more of a campy a
dark comedy although while being
legitimately disturbing I personally
didn't see that the series transition
into anime format would be this smooth
and was partially expecting some
backlash due to the violence I guess the
series has to thank issues OCO reviewers
for absorbing much of the mandatory
seasonal heat from Western journalism
next on the list is another supernatural
show inspector to be honest this kind of
show caught me by surprise at first
glance I was thinking something along
the lines of bleach - the DBZ power
levels and magical swords it's that or
noragami another show that I really
loved back then and that you should also
check out however
inspector has turned out to be one a fun
mystery solving show much of the show's
run time is spent on spirit mediator got
to go college student guru and his
ex-girlfriend Saki solving the mystery
behind steal woman Nana say a Spectre
running amok and wreaking havoc around
town just what is this ghost all about
how did it come to be and how does it
get put in its place most of the show's
12 episodes revolve around the case and
it turned out to be a slow burn that
keeps me anticipating each new episode
as weeks go by the amount of talking
might not be everyone's cup of tea but
the characters provide more than enough
entertainment to keep fans engaged there
are some action and supernatural powers
involved but unlike noragami inspector
is a mystery series through and through
[Music]
next on the list is keep your hands off
ezel can every now and then you get
these animes that delve deep into the
creation process of the medium it seems
to be a trend that's becoming more and
more common but won't ultimately blow up
as much as the Issyk I of cute girls
doing cute things onra done before much
ibarguen and shirobako had done it
before
he's agains the newest entry to that
line of anime talking about how anime
gets made however unlike the mention
shows I see ezel Ken as a more relaxed
and less technical counterpart I'd admit
that this show feels a lot less serious
than those mentioned with it taking
pride in its frantic and wacky energy
there's not really much to the plot
besides three girls starting an
animation Club without a strong or
compelling plot to drive the show
forward either Ken looks to keep us
entertained with its main characters and
boy does it do a great job of that every
now and then the girls drift into a
surreal fantasy sequence a nifty twist
that really shows us how much the
creator's love making their ideas run
wild both in and out of universe overall
either Ken's
random and fun and I think he can be one
of the more memorable hits this winter
season
[Music]
claiming the top spot on the list is it
invaded it invaded is an anime original
that revolves around the MS Ohana may a
mysterious system that allows people to
dive into the minds of murderers
the catch is there only people who've
killed someone are permitted to dive
into the ED Wells manifestations of a
murderous mind it invaded tells a story
of Sakai doe a former detective who's
had his fair share of experience with
murder play may be considered a renegade
assisting the police force Sakai doe
soon realizes that the whole system and
the serial killers that he despises so
much may hold secrets far beyond what
he's figured out it invaded certainly
brings back some memories of psychopaths
an inception for me an apt name for a
series then seeing as it is the general
term for an individual's unconscious
mind the use of technology in order to
explore the mind of a criminal is a
concept that's now been around for quite
some time and it amazes me to find
another show like that this season will
we look back at this season and consider
it invaded as one of the best hits of
2020 only time will tell
that's it for this list and it frankly
still amazes me to see how many new
anime are coming out all of the shows
look promising especially to their
target demographics and I can't believe
that I overlooked some of them by
looking back at the season that brought
us epics like Vinland saga and Beyond at
the supposedly star-studded spring 2020
season take another look at that list as
well isn't that a lot of shows that you
might be missing out on now's the time
to start watching them one at a time and
finding the next gem as we await the
coming season
with that I hope things get a lot better
for you take care stay safe and I'll see
you next time